- Hi, welcome back.
If I'm shopping, it's from
my couch, with my laptop
and my sweatpants and my
kids on either side of me,
who in that moment are
purposefully chipping
away at the bliss I'm trying
to immerse myself in called
retail therapy, but that's why I'm excited
that we've teamed up with Ru La La,
an online store where you can
get all these high quality,
designer items at totally
different price points.
And every once in a while
we also get the privilege of shopping
with one of our friends.
So without further ado, here
now with this week's hot
Rue La La items is my friend,
Kahlana Barfield Brown.
- Hi Drew.
- Hi Kahlana.
Oh, I love doing this with you.
- I love doing this, Drew.
We have some incredible
items from Rue La La today.
Starting with this
Frette Plush Velour Robe
that I have on.
I have it on in white.
You have it in the rose color.
It is so incredible.
It's so comfortable.
And I love that it's unisex.
So it's for his or her.
And I love that it also has
this great shawl collar,
nice big pockets, and
the material is so great.
Now get this.
This is normally $300.
Today, we are getting it at $59.99.
That's an 80% discount.
It really is a steal.
- Frette is a serious company.
- It really is.
- So if you can get this at
that price, that is incredible.
- It really is a great deal.
Okay. So you and I love to
talk about beauty products.
We love to talk about
the latest and greatest
and what really works.
So today we have this
incredible beauty product,
it's from Kora Organics.
It's their Noni Glow Sleeping Mask.
And it's filled with
moisturizing ingredients
like coconut milk.
It's a clear gel formula
you put on before bed,
you wake up, rinse your face,
and it gives you an instant glow.
- This is Miranda Kerr's company.
- It absolutely is, and
this normally is $48.
Today we're getting it for $23.99.
(gasps)
That's a 50% discount.
(laughing)
(crowd applauds)
- I'm sorry.
You can look well rested for $23
Over and over.
- And this is actually a big bottle.
- Yeah.
- And it's,
I mean, I think a little goes a long way
with this mask as well.
- This is amazing.
- Okay next is like self
care on another level.
It is this you uComfy
Heated Foot Massager.
It really feels like you
have a foot masseuse at home.
- And right now it's a very difficult time
and you know certain cities
and states have different restrictions.
- Right.
- Also,
I don't care what times we're in.
It's hard to get out of the
house to do things like this
for yourself, all right.
Put your foot in there. Ready?
- Yes.
- I'm gonna turn it on.
- Okay, let's go.
- I'm gonna crank it
to like the, oh my God.
- It feels so good.
- Oh my God.
- And I love that you
can adjust the pressure.
So if you're someone who
likes a little pressure,
you got it.
If you like a lot of pressure, you got it.
There's five different levels.
- There is like sadistic
reflexology happening
within my bubble right now.
- There is.
- And I love it!
- I love it.
- This is like, God!
I have to say that I didn't
think you could get this kind
of action from a machine
like this.
- Oh yes,
it really is powerful, I love it.
- That doesn't sound right.
- It's honestly,
it's a game changer.
- How much does this cost?
- This normally-
- I'll pay anything!
- I know, right?
So it normally goes for $299.99-
- Sold!
- But today
we are getting it for one $110.99.
That is a 63% discount.
- Done! Done, done, done.
This is, I have to say,
this is very different
than what I would think.
- Yeah.
- Guess what baby.
You are mine.
- Right?
And we have it in two colors.
We have it in that red and
we also have it in silver.
- Okay. What else do we have Kahlana,
- Okay last but not least-
- That can top that,
I don't know.
- I know,
it's gonna be hard to top,
but last but not least,
we all need our comfortable underwear.
We have Hanky Panky Low-rise Thongs.
They are so comfortable.
It's their classic stretchy lace material
but we're getting sets of
three for a great price.
- How much?
- Normally these go for $72
for three, today we're
getting them at $34.99.
That's a 51% discount.
- I have to admit I've
been wearing a g-string
under my pants because I wear
like a very full bottom brief.
- Mm hmm.
- And I just,
when I'm in my off time it's like,
you know the baggier the better.
- Right. (laughs)
- But when I'm at work,
I want to try and you know,
not have VPL.
- Right.
- Visible panty lines.
- Panty lines.
- This is a thing.
I don't know, what do you guys have?
Like, butt huggers situation?
What's the thing for you?
'Cause women, we fret.
We really, we Frette,
ha ha!
- We Frette.
- We Frette about our panty lies.
- [Kahlana] It's a no, no, it's a no, no.
- And the reason Hanky
Panky got so famous was
because they are like a non-VPL
visible panty line situation.
And these are beautiful.
- And they're comfortable.
They're comfortable.
- That's the other thing.
- We need that.
- [Drew] And I will say
these are the most famous in underwear.
- Yeah. They really are.
So to get them at this price
point is honestly like a steal
and we have so many different
prints and patterns.
- I mean, I will say
too, in all earnestness,
it is hard for us to carve
out this time for ourselves.
- It is.
- This is self care.
This is luxuriating.
- Yup. And I think it's
like worth the investment.
And when you're getting it at a deal,
it makes it even greater.
- For all of you at home,
you can find these items at
Ruelala.com/TheDrewBarrymoreShow
or Drew La La as we're saying,
And remember these
deals are only available
while supplies last.
So grab 'em, cheers.
- Cheers.
- And we'll be right back.
(crowd cheers)
(upbeat music)